This DNews episode is brought to you by Casper.
When you sleep are you on your stomach?
Your LEFT side?
Do you wake up on the "wrong" side of the
bed?
All of these things have been looked at by
science!
If you sleep on your LEFT SIDE you're probably
more creative, if[a] you sleep on the RIGHT
side of the bed, that's the bad side, and
sleeping on your stomach makes your dreams
more… sexyyy.
Science says, our sleeping positions matter.
In fact, according to a study conducted back
in April, the distance you sleep from your
partner while in bed, indicates how happy
you are!
According to a survey of 1,000 people in Edinburgh,
Scotland, most people, 42-percent, sleep back
to back, and 31-percent facing the same direction,
only 4 percent sleep face to face.
Extroverts tend to sleep closer, in general,
but 86 percent of those who slept less than
an inch apart were happy in their relationship;
while people who slept 30 inches apart were
far less likely to be happy.
Remembering that this is survey data, so prone
to bias, it would seem when humans sleep further
apart we're less happy.
Which I can tell you I've definitely experienced.
But this ain't the first sleep position study:
back in 2003, Sleep Assessment and Advisory
Service in the UK broke down the six basic
sleep positions -- and compared to their personality
types.
The study included 1,000 people from Australia,
Japan, Hong Kong, China, and Singapore, and,
obviously, the UK.
People who sleep in the fetal position, according
to science, are quote "tough on the outside,
but sensitive at heart," which amounts to
41-percent of the respondents, and twice as
many women.
But fetal is one of six possible sleeping
positions: fetal, freefall, starfish, soldier,
log, and yearner.
Starfish is the rarest, and after fetus, the
log is the most common.
Sleeping in these positions can indicate a
tendency toward [b]acceptance, or cynicism;
whether you're suspicious or friendly, or
even whether you're brash or good at taking
criticism!
It's pretty cool, though it feels a little
like astrology to me.
Medically speaking, the freefall is good for
digestion, while the starfish and soldier
often lead to breathing issues, including
snoring.
Yet ANOTHER study of 3,000 adults found there
really is a wrong side of the bed.
It's the right side…
25 percent of people who tend toward the left,
see a positive outlook on life; while only
18 percent of right-siders see that.
66 percent of the leftie-sleepers believe
they're calmer in crises, have more confidence
and are more likely to be in permanent employment
-- on top of all that, 31 percent of them
love their job; while only 18 percent of rightie-sleepers
do.
In the end, how you sleep affects way more
than just… well, your night's sleep.
Sleeping on your stomach, for instance.
A study in the journal Dreaming found that
people who sleep on their stomachs, report
dreams about "sex" and "persecution" and "erotomania"
-- or the delusion that a celebrity is in
love with them.
It's weird, and science isn't sure why, but
there you have it.
More research is definitely needed.
I'm a freefall sleeper for sure… though
I don't agree with the personality assessment...
What about you?
How do you sleep?
Side?
Stomach?
Back?
Now’s probably a good time to shout out
our sponsor - Casper is American-made, affordable,
obsessively engineered mattresses created
from memory foam and latex.
No springs!
The mattress stays cool, with just the right
sink-to-bounce ratio.
You can buy it online and it ships right to
you.
Try it out and get 50 bucks off by visiting
Casper.com slash DNews and using the code
DNews.
If you love it, awesome!
If not you've got 100 days to try it out,
free delivery and easy returns.
Meantime, let us know your sleeping style
in the comments,